there's a group of people who by your
own admission are disaffected
and angry and alienated and young
and i'm helping them and why is that
exactly a problem
what is it that i'm supposed to be doing
with them just out of curiosity what do
you think
if you had your druthers would i ignore
them
returning to the show today is my very
good friend our very first guest
man who premiered the ben shapiro show
sunday special jordan peterson
he returns to discuss his newest book
beyond order 12 more rules for life
and we're going to jump into as many of
the new rules as we have time for today
in 2018 this book's predecessor 12 rules
for life an antidote to chaos along with
a slew of viral youtube videos
transformed jordan into a pop culture
luminary
since he has last joined us he's
traveled the world speaking to hundreds
of thousands of people
influencing listeners to better
understand and take control of their
lives
a couple of years have passed since 12
rules for life was released it continues
to live at the top of all the book
charts his latest looks to be
captivating readers in exactly the same
way
recently leftists had the audacity to
paint jordan as a murderous nazi in
marvel comics
that's just the latest in the swipes
left is taken at him we're going to talk
about what it is about jordan that has
made him public enemy
number one we'll also discuss how we
become our best selves and what causes
us to admire others
how you can learn mythology and religion
to understand your life
and jordan's thoughts on love sex
romance and relationships and connection
to your humanity
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special this show is
sponsored by expressvpn don't like big
tech and the government spying on you
visit expressvpn.com
ben just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with jordan
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation is to become a
member go over to dailywire.com become a
member you'll have access to all of the
full conversations with every one of our
awesome
guests jordan peterson thanks so much
for joining the show all right ben it's
really good to see you
thanks for the it's fantastic to see you
thank you and congratulations on the
brand new book the book of course
is it beyond order 12 more rules for
life it is moving
and it is fulfilling it is is a it is a
wonderful wonderful
piece of work and i think it's going to
be inspirational to a lot of folks
thanks ben i
appreciate that a lot so let's talk
about
before we get to the actual contents of
the books i want to talk about some of
the rules that are in there which
again i think there's a lot there that
people are going to find inspirational
and thought-provoking
let's talk about the media's treatment
of you so the media's treatment of you
for
a long time really since you sort of a
rose to international prominence
has been this this mode of attack
whether it is the bbc suggesting that
your vicious sexist or the new york
times suggesting that you want to force
women into marriage
or whether now it is ta-nehisi coates
writing comics that portray you as red
skull captain america's
rival the the nazi he's a he's a nazi
character
what do you make of magic super villain
nazi because nazi when nazi isn't enough
when comparing you to hitler isn't
enough there's always red skull
i think it's kind of hit a limit because
the next step is satan
[Music]
right i mean that's where you go after
red skull and uh
what do i make of it oh thank you for
your defense by the way
much appreciated oh yeah of course i
mean i should say look
there have been people in the media
who've been
supportive of me from the beginning i
would say
in canada for example there's four or
five people who
i think are among canada's top
journalists who
have been firm defenders of me right
from the beginning
and so it isn't every single person in
the mainstream media although
there's a disproportionate number of
people in the mainstream media
who go after me compared i think to
my popularity versus unpopularity in the
general public
and i i've i've thought about it a lot
i'm not exactly sure what to make of it
um i certainly wasn't sure what to make
of the last
red skull episode it was absolutely
shocking to me it took me
about 12 hours to recover because i
couldn't believe it was
actually real to begin with it was so
surreal i i found out about it on
twitter somebody just sent me the
cartoon and
the first thing i thought was that it
was a photoshop uh
mock-up you know just another meme and
then i looked into it a bit and then i
was really
confused that this had occurred it just
seemed especially when i found out who
the author was you know
so that was a double shock and and then
i
i decided to because i'm i'm feeling
better
and i have my sense of humor back at
least to some degree and so
i decided i just play with it instead of
any of the other possible options that
were open to me
and that's worked out extremely well
we've raised about 150
000 for charity because of but it isn't
disappearing
it doesn't seem to disappear and every
so often somebody comes out of the
woodwork and takes another swipe
at me and hoping that perhaps i don't
know hoping
i don't know what hoping that this will
be the time that i finally
get wiped out and you know that's
happened
three or four times in major media
outlets this year alone
uh uh the woman who interviewed me for
gq
um she wrote a couple articles
one in the atlantic monthly helen lewis
and she still seems to be
quite disappointed in the fact that i
exist and decade can head in the lun
in the times in in in the uk she was
quite the piece of work and then
this last episode with tennehisi coates
i i thought about i'll tell you what i
think you tell me what you think about
this
you know there are people like me uh in
some ways like stephen pinker jonathan
height
who are public intellectuals who are
standing up against
critical race theory and the worst of
the leftist
propaganda um there are
rationalists and atheists in the main
scientists
and i have one foot in that camp but i
also have
a foot in the mythological dramatic
religious camp and you know nellie
bowles who's one of the journalists who
came after me
she's the one who wrote the mia culpa
three or four months ago pointing out
that she used her position
to destroy people's reputation just so
she could attract attention to herself
surprise surprise and you know she
called me defender of the patriarchy
which was a
ironic in some sense her use of that but
also an insult at least from her
perspective but
that's me both sides of it the
rationalist side the enlightenment side
and the religious side
and so have at her boys
that's what i think so i can't think of
any other explanation really
no i think i think that's right i mean
when when i saw what what
coats had done in the captain america
comics and i actually think that it does
go to something root about our
civilization at this point because
you talk a lot jordan obviously about
mythology and the power of myth and
the most american form of myth at this
point in time are the comic books right
i mean graphic novels are the form of
american myth particularly
the marvel universe which is the single
biggest cinematic universe in movie
history at this point
right and and to take captain america
who's the iconic american figure turn
him on his head
so that he's opposing some of the stuff
that you are saying and what you are
saying is reflective of nazi propaganda
it what what it really does is it does
place you in the position
of satan except that the same people who
very often are celebrating
satan in in sort of his juxtaposition to
god
i would never treat satan that way i
think that you're worse than satan
because satan
is featured in little mass sex videos is
sort of something that ought to be
imitated right there's a celebration of
his rebellious spirit
yeah you're you're foot in that
religious inspirational world he does
differentiate you from a lot of the
other people
who the left has is somewhat targeted
but has decided is not really worthwhile
that's why i think that the way that you
were described in that comic book for
people who missed it basically the
implication was that red skull was
driving people to join
hydra by by issuing his 10 rules for
order
and talking about the greatness of
civilization and how you should make
your room
and and all of this stuff is is driving
many on the left
up a wall specifically because it's
inspirational the left knows that when
it comes to driving the human heart
it's not enough to be a rationalist you
actually have to offer an inspirational
program and i think this is the great
irony is that folks like coates
they do offer an inspirational program
but their inspirational program
is an inspiration to tear down exactly
the institutions of western civilization
you defend which is why he has created
this dichotomy
yeah well it's something that everyone
needs to take seriously across the
political spectrum
i mean it's quite clear that we need
a story along with our politics
and that's because the human heart
demands an adventure
and that's especially true if you're
young you know the
the developmental psychologist john
piaget who's
who's a genius a recognized genius
he has a stage of development he posited
the last stage of development as in
adolescence
as the messianic stage it isn't talked
about much in
developmental psychology literature i
mean piaget was actually
trying to reconcile religion and science
that was his life's work and he
investigated the development of ethics
empirically
in an attempt to bridge the gap between
the is and
isn't ought and um and he was very very
serious about that
it drove his whole enterprise in any
case he pointed out that
there is a stage of development in late
adolescence that he called the messianic
stage where people are
looking for i suppose they're catalyzing
their identity at the broadest possible
level which
which we would describe as religious i
don't care if you're religious or not
that's irrelevant to this discussion
at the point at the highest level of
generality
your identity the best language to
describe your identity happens to be
religious which is why we have a
religious language speaking purely from
a psychological perspective and
what that means is that there has to be
a call to adventure
in order to keep people motivated
to move forward in their life both as
individuals and as
members of society and look george
orwell really knew this
about the fascists for example i mean
orwell was a
profound anti-fascist i mean profound in
the emotional sense and also in the
analytic sense and
but he recognized very early and and had
the courage also to point out
that the nazis had conjured up
a mythos that was unbelievably powerful
and that
the rationalist west had nothing in its
armament to contend with that
and fascism in in some sense is it's
it's more difficult to mount a rational
defense against than communism
because the fascists do use non-verbal
appeal
and and hitler used fire and imagery and
fashion
and architecture and art and and culture
in the broadest sense to move his
political platform
forward the leftists
in especially in the us are
quite good at the dramatic end of
politics you know and and
the the antifa riots that sort of thing
the black life
matters black lives matter protests
they're appealing to young people and
you can imagine
i always remember i saw this kid in
montreal once he's about 17 and
he's dressed in punk clothes he's a big
kid six foot five like a big powerful
kid
and he was standing on the corner of
this outdoor shopping mall with two pink
shopping bags in his hand
and he looked like a fool and it was
partly because he felt like a fool
because there he was this like monster
standing there with these pink shopping
bags and i looked at him and i thought
geez you know if you went and offered
him an overseas adventure
a war-like overseas adventure he dropped
those damn bags and he'd be gone in a
second
and no wonder and so it's
incumbent on us to realize that that
call to adventure is necessary and
that it has to be built in in some
manner into our political
uh our political thinking and the left
is very very good at that
they're much better the radical left
they're much better than the left
centrists
and they're much better than the
centrist right now trump managed that to
some degree with his populism
but not to the same degree as the
intellectuals the dramatic intellectuals
on the left
i think that this points to you know
some serious problems at the heart of
sort of classical liberalism and i
consider myself you know a conservative
socially and a classical liberal when it
comes to the role of government but it
does point to some real problems with
the the heart of classical liberalism
and the rationalist enlightenment side
of the argument uh that there is no
greater appeal to the human heart other
than sort of what works and pragmatism
and there has to be something on the
other end of that i want to ask you
about that in just
one second jordan first let's talk about
your privacy on the internet
well folks we know that big tech is not
a big fan of people on the right side of
the aisle
everybody should have the right to
express themselves freely but the big
tech monopoly
instead they've opted for silencing
tactics and censorship well one way that
i fight back against big tech control
i use expressvpn if you've ever wondered
how free to access tech giants make all
their money the answer is they track
your searches your video history every
single thing you click on
and then they build a profile on you and
then they sell it well when you use the
expressvpn app on your computer or phone
you anonymize a lot of your online
presence by hiding that ip address
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and sell to advertisers what's
more
expressvpn encrypts 100 of your network
data to protect you from eavesdroppers
and cybercriminals
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it just takes one click to protect
all of your devices which is why
expressvpn is rated number one by cnet
and wired you need to protect your data
you wouldn't leave any of your other
assets out there unprotected why
wouldn't you protect
what you do on your computer revoke big
tech's right to your data secure your
internet with the vpn i trust for online
protection
visit expressvpn.com that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
get three extra months for free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more so jordan
you were speaking a moment ago about the
sort of lack of meaning that people are
looking for particularly young men and
it really is a
a big thing that young men seem to have
lost meaning post-modernism
killed the the scientific rationalist
world and the post-modernists have
decided to substitute for that a certain
utopian vision of the remolding of
american society
in in terms of what they call equity but
really amounts to tribal dynamics
and you see this over and over the
radical left pushing its own version of
utopianism
classical liberals have been
wrong-footed i think by the need for
something more fulfilling which is why
classical liberalism
always relied on an unspoken assumption
that you were going to find meaning in
your family you were going to find
meaning in religious community you were
going to find meaning
in bettering your social life outside of
government but when that unspoken
understanding just dissipated when when
religion started to to fall apart
all that was left was well let's just be
rational with one another there's not
much inspiring there and i think that's
why you see
that across the board a drive toward
irrationalism
a certain level of romanticism
dominating the society to the point
where
irrationalism is much more prized than
rationalism if you make a rational point
if you cite data
very often this is now considered not
only in politic but but
damaging and dangerous the other thing
that that
ideology does and the the radical
leftists are all
also very good at this is that it
provides you with a local a convenient
local
for the for the uh existence of evil
and so if you reflexively identify the
patriarchy with evil
well first of all that's a powerful idea
it's it
independent of its broad merit it's a
it's
true now it's not the only truth and
it's not the complete truth
but it's true the reason it's true is
because every hierarchical system
hierarchical system degenerates
tends to degenerate in the direction of
power and
all hierarchical systems are less than
they could be
and that's partly because of the
possibility that power and deceit will
corrupt them
but also partly because we're willfully
blind and
deceitful in our own personal lives and
so when you
tell young people that the cause of the
trouble they see around them in the
world and maybe even the disquiet in
their own heart
is the malevolent inadequacy of their
society
that rings true and they don't hear the
rest of the story
you know and it's the rest of the story
that i've been trying to tell they don't
hear the story that yeah don't forget
about the evil and corruption that
exists in your own heart
and don't forget about the fact that
nature
in this wondrous goddess as portrayed by
the anti-human
environmentalists and i by that i don't
mean all environmentalists by the way
that wonderful goddess nature is also
trying to
make you ill and kill you at all times
and so
but the story that corruption exists in
hierarchical structure
and that that's a consequence of
malevolence
the malevolent use of power and deceit
that's true
so it's very motivating especially if
you're young and you're looking for an
adventure now it's also
too convenient which is one of its
tremendous dangers because
unless you're taught to look within and
identify the malevolence there
as the primary moral obligation
then you now have an excuse and a moral
justification to take out
all of your negative emotion your
hostility your resentment everything
about you that's unexamined
on the demonic enemy and
of course that's that that degenerates
with extraordinary
rapidity have we as we've seen over and
over and over
so it's up to the it's up to the
centrists on both sides to
to deal with this i've been talking to a
lot of the optimist
rationalist types on my podcast matt
ridley and
bjorn lomberg and well in height and
pinker
more more distantly but more recently uh
loan bergen
and ridley and and uh marion toopey who
who's written a lovely book on uh
human progress uh 10 things everyone
needs to know about
human progress it's something like that
huh anyways
one of the things we discussed
consistently was the difficulty in
promoting the message that all three of
these men
are very aware of which is that from a
material perspective
in terms of absolute privation
worldwide humanity is way better off on
virtually every dimension you could
possibly measure than ever
and and most of that improvement has
occurred in the last 40 years and it's
been revolutionary in its speed
and no one knows this
and so it's very important to know to
try to think through
why that is like that's such a positive
message now
i talked to russell brandt about this
and i'm bringing him up for a reason
he's
he's a lefty by temperament and by heart
and
his first objection but he's very
thoughtful and quick
his first objection you know i pointed
out all this data showing that by every
possible objective measure
everything is way better than it was
certainly a hundred years ago but
certainly even 20 years ago um even on
the environmental front in the main
and he said well what about disparity of
distribution so there's the problem of
absolute level of wealth let's say
that's improving but there is still
tremendous disparity
and of course that that is fair enough
you could even point out that
the role of the left is to provide a
conscientious voice for
for that's constantly attending to the
fact of continuing disparity regardless
of absolute level of wealth
and fair enough but but
having said all that it's a great
mystery that
incremental optimism is not sufficiently
motivating and you can't just wish human
nature is going to change it's not going
to change we got to tell a better story
and i also think that's why i'm a target
i think it's because i am actually
trying to tell a better story and i'm
actually having some success with it
so i totally agree with that and and
that really does bring us to the book
because one of the things that folks
should know about
all of your books is that they are very
intimate very personal
you talk about yourself but you also
speak in in a way that most writers do
not you use
second person pronouns i mean you speak
directly to the reader you say
you feel this way you think this way and
a lot of people read they say i do think
that way this is a person who's speaking
directly to me in a way that
you know mainstream political books very
often do not they consider me sort of a
widget in whatever
ideology they're pushing or or they're
considering the value of systems or not
systems
but you sort of end around that and i
think that in many ways that's what
members of the left find so so
threatening is because if you're a
member of the left and you believe
that all individuals are essentially
just the outgrowths of institutions
and therefore that all change by
individuals is going to be insufficient
and that it must be societal change that
that creates individual change
you're a threat because you're telling
people well you know the systems
can certainly get better but the main
threat to you is you
and that is a deeply threatening message
to people and if people find fulfillment
in that message
then the left really does have a problem
because if people start improving their
lives within the system
and not blaming the system for their
problems and instead
recognizing that that they can improve
their life that's what
members love tape most of all you know
you talk about in the book jordan the
fact that people are constantly coming
up to you and they're saying things like
you know i i was leading a dissolute
life
i read your book i started taking your
advice and i've turned it around and now
i'm doing much better in life
and you know i'm blessed to have much
the same experience from a lot of people
who listen to the show people who have
been homeless who now have graduated
harvard law school
people who were single moms and and then
and then decided to to take a college
course and and figure out their lives
people who have made mistakes and turn
their mistakes around
and to me those are inspirational
stories i think that because those
inspirational stories exist that i think
is why people find you to be such a
threat it's because so many people are
inspired by the stuff that you say
and change their life individually
without putting all of their iron focus
on a system that the left is mainly
focused on tearing down
i defy anyone to go read 10 000
comments on my youtube channels and not
come away
with a much better with a much refreshed
view
of human nature the comments are
in the main unbelievably positive and
not in the naive sense they're positive
in a thoughtful sense
and in a communal sense because the
people who are making comments on the
lectures are
also commenting on each other and
there's ideological
babble on both sides i would say that's
probably
five percent of the comments and
generally i believe they're
written by people who didn't actually
watch the lecture because they're
often out of context but in any case 95
of the comments are thoughtful but also
extremely positive which is very rare in
a social media comment landscape
which tends to be very very toxic and so
i think that's absolutely great and it
certainly has that impact on me when i
when i read it um but then here's
something else that
i i've observed in the
media attacks that have been directed
towards me
they're not just directed towards me
they're
well first they're directed to who they
think i am so that's kind of interesting
to begin with but
more than directed to me and more
perniciously
is that they're directed to those who
are hypothetically following me
now i don't regard myself as someone
with followers i regard myself
as someone with viewers listeners and
readers
and that's different but in any case
my typical follower so goes the story is
a disaffected angry young white male
and for a while i
in some sense pushed back against that
and said well
my audience about 70 mail but youtube
skews mail so
that's perhaps part of the reason and i
see no evidence that it's
particularly limited racially or
ethnically especially when i
watch see my lecture crowds and when i
meet people on the street but
but then i started to realize that that
was the wrong response the
right response is why does it
disturb you so much
that there's a group of people who by
your own admission are disaffected
and angry and alienated and young
and i'm helping them and why is that
exactly a problem
what is it that i'm supposed to be doing
with them just out of curiosity what do
you think
if you had your druthers would i ignore
them
would no one talk to them is that
actually what you want
well the answer seems quite clear that
that is exactly what's wanted
that's what's held forth because there's
this implicit assumption
in all of this critique that in my very
act of
aid i'm doing something immoral immoral
enough to be parodied let's say is red
skull
so just what the hell's going on here
it's like why is that
now uh fodder for
for parody or slander precisely
i mean do you debate the fact that i'm
helping while you go read the comments
yourself
and see what you think and so then and
then
i thought about that a bunch too i
thought well what is it
with with men the men that i'm speaking
to let's say um
why are they responding positively why
do they come to my lectures
the biblical lectures even which is very
surprising right just what the hell are
men doing in a biblical lecture
especially young men especially when
they could go do anything else and they
have to pay for it
it's like what are they doing coming to
this lecture well
if the patriarchy is an evil tyranny
then the appropriate attitude towards
any male
ambition is to not treat it as ambition
but to treat it as
nascent drive to tyrannical power which
is certainly what
uh foucault would recommend for example
or dereda because it's all power and so
if you see some young man
trying to stand up and better himself in
any
dimension you're not going to trust that
you're going to identify that as
the manifestation of tyrannical power
and clearly if the patriarchy is a
malevolent
tyrant then any sign of the desire to
contribute it to it should be
at minimum not encouraged
but more subtly criticized and
discouraged at every possible
opportunity and that's our culture
so in a second i want to get to a lot of
the thoughts here that we've been
talking about are embedded in some of
the rules that you talk about
in your book beyond order 12 more rules
for life which of course is breaking all
sales records as per your usual
uh this is the way that jordan's books
sell at this point we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
your sleep quality you know it's pretty
obvious when i don't get a good night's
rest i mean everybody can see it but
here's the thing
helix sleep makes sure it doesn't happen
very often because
i have a mattress made by helix sleep
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
why would you buy a mattress made for
somebody else with helix you're getting
a mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that they
have several different mattress models
to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks it's been great getting unboxing
videos from so many of you who also
found the helix mattress of your dreams
if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz order the mattress and the
mattress comes right to your doorship
for free
you never need to go to a mattress store
again he looks awesome you don't need to
take my word for it
although you probably should helix is
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine so
head on over to helixsleep.com ben take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress
that'll give you the best sleep
of your life they've got a 10-year
warranty you can try it out for 100
nights risk-free they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will we took the helix sleep
quiz my wife and i we got a mattress
made just for us
and it is just amazing it's a great
mattress helix is offering up to 200
bucks off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com jordan so i want
to jump into
some of the rules that you talk about in
the book beyond order 12 more rules for
life because
again there's a lot of depth here and a
lot of nuance that i think that
a lot of people want to deny you which
is usually the way this thing
sort of goes is that if you have a lot
of people who follow what you do
and you have a general world view
opposed to that of of many in the media
then you are robbed of all nuance and
everything turns immediately into your
right-wing patriarchal fascist
that's just what it boils down to it's
always your evil stupid
uh or or incompetent those are the three
slurs that are usually tossed out there
yeah so
who happens who happened somewhat oddly
to take things like harry potter
seriously
so it's another reason that it's not
that easy to pigeonhole me it's like
okay i'm all those things but
now i'm taking pop culture seriously i
i'm thinking that when people are
reading harry potter they're not just
fools that this isn't
trivial just like the marvel universe
isn't trivial
people wouldn't be spending billions of
dollars on it if it was trivial they
wouldn't be reading
you know half a dozen 600 page books
when they're 10 years old
which is what happened with harry potter
if it was trivial and so the other thing
that happens is the
mainstream critics of the type we've
been describing just wave their hands
about that and say you know i'm
wandering off into some
intellectually contemptible mystical
landscape but that's not
the case at all i'm taking this very
very seriously
and when something happens like the
harry potter phenomenon or the
captain marvel marvel universe phenomena
anyone with any sense who's a
sociological or psychological observer
is going to try to get to the bottom of
that
and so i'm doing that with the books and
but you know like i said the consequence
of that is it's just hand washing
i mean that's part and parcel of an
entire gaslighting effort by the media
to
to radically shift culture and then when
you know that culture is radically
shifted
uh then they say how dare you notice
that culture is radically shifting or if
you point out that something is quite
popular may have a deeper meaning
they know that that's why they're making
it that's why they're monetizing it but
the moment you point it out they say how
dare you even pay attention to the fact
that this is an important thing in
culture this just shows that you're
silly
it's all honestly a childish gaslighting
game but
i want to get to some of the rules in
the book the first rule that you talk
about jordan
is not to carelessly denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement and
here
this is really a post-partisan message
it's a recognition
that conservatives respect for tradition
respect for the past is really a respect
for institutions that have been built up
over the course of thousands of years
in conjunction with a an increasingly
good understanding of human nature
and that has to be balanced with a a
recognition that we can't
get so tied up in these rules that it
becomes impossible to extricate
ourselves from them we can't
we can't fossilize these rules and turn
them into uh something that is that is
unchangeable in any way that in essence
we should be cautious about
changing the rules of society they
should be changeable so we shouldn't
obliterate them
but we also have to you have to know the
rules of the game before you can change
the rules of the game
and if you're playing uh if you're
playing calvin ball and in calvin and
hobbes and the rules of the chain
the game change every second that's not
a game anymore that's just an exercise
of power but you also have to recognize
that sometimes the rules do have to
change how do you balance those two
things
well i think the first thing you do is
vow to tell the truth
so that you don't follow yourself up
and then i think you pay attention to
what manifests itself to you as
meaningful
because i think that meaning i literally
think
and i think this empirically as well as
spiritually let's say
i believe that the instinct of meaning
signifies the optimal information
processing function of the nervous
system so when you're balanced
properly between order and novelty
or order and chaos that that
manifests itself to you as deep
engagement
and that's a signal and it's not merely
cognitive it's way deeper than that
it's a signal that you're in the right
place doing the right thing
at the right time and everyone wants
that
and everyone wants that all the time
like images of paradise
are representations of that state of
being
so it's there for you but but there are
preconditions
and one of the preconditions is that you
strive to do the best
to aim at the best and that has to be
your fundamental ethos
that and it's a decision that despite
all
of the calamities of being that your
primary ethical obligation
is to work for the betterment of
yourself and
others and that's a very complex
decision because
there's so much of you that's twisted
and turned against
existence itself because of its
suffering and
complexity it's very hard to get your
head straight about that and so
you get warped and twisted by resentment
and
and and deceit and and temptations of
various sorts
so that has to be straightened out so
that you're aiming
in the right direction and and
once once you manage that or perhaps in
conjunction with that
you have to watch what you say you have
to say what you believe to be true
not because you're trying to accomplish
something
specific with what you're saying but
because you're attempting to represent
what's happening
in front of you as accurately as you
possibly can
and let go of the consequences
and so and then you search for this
you search for this engage you search
for the engagement that that produces
and this is one of the things i love
about long-form podcasts
is that when a conversation takes off
properly and it's dynamic and unscripted
both of the participants are striving to
keep that sense of engagement constantly
at play and if they do that then the
conversation is
engaging in deep and gets as deep as the
people involved can manage
and they'll pull the entire audience
along for the ride
and everyone is thrilled about that
that's logos that's the manifestation of
logos
and it's deeply meaningful it's there's
nothing more meaningful than
that and and that's a that's a sign that
you've got that balance right
you want to be there all the time that's
the goal is to be there all the time
of course that's a lofty goal and and
very difficult to attain but
but that's that's the end game so jordan
in a second i want to ask you how do
people aim for the best and how do we
define the best such that we don't fall
into sort of a radical subjectivism
where we all define the best for
ourselves and
the best can mean anything we want it to
mean and ask you about that in just one
second first
let's talk about for just one second the
nature of the employees at your company
so let's say you own a company and you
need the best people working for you it
can be very difficult to find
the best people to work for you quickly
and efficiently if you're a business
owner who's hiring you probably face a
lot of challenges when it comes to
finding the right person for your role
these days that's why hiring can often
feel like you're trying to find a needle
in a haystack
sure you could post your job to some job
board but then all you can do is hope
the right person comes along
instead why not try zip recruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
ben guest when you post a job on zip
recruit it gets sent out to over 100 top
job sites with just one click then
ziprecruiter's amazing matching
technology finds people with the right
skills
and experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply
in fact zip recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day it's no wonder
over 2.3 million businesses have come to
zip recruiter
for their hiring needs go check out zip
recruiter right now because again
it can be very tough to staff up we here
at daily wear been using zip recruiter
for years
for precisely this reason while other
companies overwhelm you with way too
many options
zip recruiter will find you what you are
looking for that needle in the haystack
right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this web address ziprecruiter.com
ben guest once again remember go to
ziprecruiter.com
b-e-n-g-u-e-s-t because i have a guest
ben guest zip recruiter is the smartest
way to hire alrighty so jordan i was
asking about
how we aim for the best and how do we
define the best such that we don't fall
into a sort of subjectivism trap
where the best is just whatever i feel
like is the best for me
or or the best for the universe but in
my own particular viewpoint is there
such a thing as an objective best that
we're all searching for
there's a transpersonal best i don't
know if it's objective
i think we need a third category which
is something like transpersonal
subjective
so it's it's the same across people but
it still
manifests itself in this objective
domain there's a technical problem with
being selfish
because you might say well it's myself
against others and i could just do what
was good for me
there's a technical problem with that
which i outlined in both books but in
particular and beyond order
said well if it's let's say you're only
acting
in accordance with what's good for you
well
which you do you mean exactly do you
mean you in the next five minutes or
the next 10 minutes or the next day or
the next week or month or
year or five years etc you get you get
the picture there's the u that extends
at
multiple levels of temporal resolution
and that's a group that you i mean
you're an old person
not yet but you will be and so
you could say that if you were
enlightened selfish you'd
act in a manner now that is best for
your 80 year old self
and so if you take yourself seriously
as an entity that exists collectively
across time
then you're faced with the problem of
the collective instantly
even if you're highly selfish so i don't
think that there is a
selfishness that's logically juxtaposed
against the interest of the collective
and i do think that there are emergent
ethics
that are inevitable i think you see them
cross species even to some degree
there are playable and non-playable
games that's a good way of looking at it
because a game is an iterated
iterated series of interactions and out
of iterated series of interactions
ethics emerges
and it emerges with a structure and and
we recognize this structure
one way we recognize that i believe and
this is also assuming that your eyes are
open and you're not lying to yourself
to too great a degree you'll be struck
with admiration for
certain people that grips you
well why well that's the manifestation
of the instinct to imitate
that grips you with admiration it's the
same sense of meaning and
it's because that person is doing
something
that signals to you the place that you
should advance to
and our cognitive architecture is
predicated on imitation to a degree
that's almost
impossible to overstate and that sense
of awe
which is an elevation of the sense of
meaning is
manifested when the admirable makes
itself present
and that's not really cognitive it's not
something you think through it's
something that grabs you now you can
make it explicit you can decompose it
you could take it apart
the idea of worship when the idea of
worship is taking
taken seriously it's
it's the injunction to imitate is to
find the highest thing you can possibly
find to admire
and then to imitate that and that grip
is that's the worship
that's the awe and that's an instinct
and it's related to
the fact that we live in social
hierarchies and we admire
those who have progressed in the
hierarchy in the direction of the goals
that we are
striving to attain it's all built
unbelievably deeply into our biology
um to a degree that hasn't been
appreciated yet or taken sufficiently
seriously
that religious instinct is real it's
real it's more real than anything else
so jordan one of the things that you
talk about and this is what so many
people have i think honed in on and i
think a lot of people find it
threatening
uh is the the fact that one of your main
messages in all of this is that
the way that you're gonna find meaning
and the people who you're gonna want to
imitate are the people who take on the
most responsibility
and in a society that focuses a lot on
rights and very very little on duties
uh that is a that is a super counter
cultural message and the fact that it's
resonating with young people
has to scare the living hell out of a
lot of people because the simple fact is
that
so much of our society is predicated on
the idea that it that it is actually
in some ways anti-social to take on
responsibility that taking on
responsibility defeats the purpose of
the infrastructures that we've created
to relieve you of the responsibility so
if you say no i don't want your help
i feel that your help is is innervating
me and my job in life
is to shy away from that supposedly
helping hand that actually is is
crippling my ability to care for myself
and my family
that scares a lot of folks who are
invested in these systems but
you really preach responsibility and i
think that's right i mean
i can't think of a single person that i
admire who is a person
who shirks in fact i i find it hard to
believe that there's anybody who people
admire who
whose main goal in life is to shirk
responsibility and engage in personal
pleasure
as much as people may talk about that
it's just not something people naturally
admire
you can see that admiration
sometimes so you can think about the
film rebel without a cause for example
there's the romantic rebel
who shirks duty because but the real
reason is he's standing up for a higher
responsibility
and refusing like blind pathological
conformity
and so you can you can get around the
responsibility problem that way and
and admire you know creative rebellion
something like that and
but but those few exceptions
apart i ask my readers just
to think for themselves about that it's
like well who do you admire and when do
you admire yourself when do you have
some self-respect
and when does your conscience bother you
do you have self-respect when you're
shouldering your responsibilities or
when you're abdicating them you might
say well i don't have any
responsibilities it's like
well do you have any goals well i don't
have any goals
well then you don't have a life it's
like you can't even
act you have to have goals there's that
just doesn't work that that that isn't
that isn't a statement that works in the
world
if you have goals you have
responsibility the responsibility is to
progress towards the goals
you can even change the goals if you
want but you can't get rid of the fact
that you have a responsibility to move
towards your goals
and you can say well i'll just dispense
with goals it's like well unless you're
like
the buddha good luck with that
and even in the buddhist case i mean he
had nirvana at his fingertips but
rejected it
to go back to redeem the world so
the only instance we know of essentially
mythologically or otherwise where there
was a detachment from goals and nirvana
attained as a consequence the
consequence of that still was the
adoption of responsibility the rejection
of
nirvana as a solitary pursuit
so and then you think about your own
life
and the life of your parents well where
do you find your meaning
well in your intimate relationship
is there responsibility there well there
is if you're if
it's a relationship that's based on
trust and love and
fidelity your children your parents
people who depend on you you're not
going to have that well
that's a responsibility and and it
wouldn't be something if
that's where the meaning was well it is
and this is my experience
i've really been thinking about this
lately about where the deepest meaning
is i was talking to this guy chris
williamson a while back and he's got
this new
kind of new podcast in the uk and i was
really struck when he interviewed me
because his
he spoke when he asked me questions he
he used no he had no speech errors
no arms likes he knows no pauses
in attention nothing and i asked him
about that he said he had been
practicing being precise in his speech
for
six years and had really mastered that
but in any case he
before he started his podcast which is
called modern wisdom he
he was a successful young man in in the
sort of
quasi-celebrity way that the culture
might
offer as a icon for admiration
he worked in nightlife and he's an
attractive guy and
he had money and he had women and he had
material success he
and good for him as far as i'm concerned
that's a lot better than failure
but he started to pursue something that
was deeper and
the podcast came out of that and he
started attending to what he was saying
i talked to him about the deep sense of
satisfaction
meaning that i have when people tell me
that
they've done something positive in their
life and that i had some
influence on that or something i said
had some influence on that it's
overwhelmingly significant and he said
he had exactly the same
experience he's like what what if what
if it was the case
all cynicism defeated with this
proposition that there isn't anything
that would actually make you
feel more engaged in your life than
taking the opportunity to take the best
in someone else and encourage that
development
what if that is what we're actually like
i think that is what we're like i
believe that
and i see it i see it happening all over
and so that's not power right that
if our hierarchies are actually based on
that most fundamentally
and the best people i've seen who are
very successful
in their hierarchies are people who take
their mentoring for example
not only with dead seriousness but take
tremendous pleasure in it
what if that's the operative principle
what if the postmodern critique of
hierarchy is so wrong that it's actually
the opposite
now that doesn't mean it can't be
corrupted
institutions get corrupted by deceit and
by power
all the time but that doesn't mean that
that's their central essence
so i tell young people you know maybe
responsibility
that's where you'll find what you need
what you desperately need
and i don't say that because i'm shaking
a stick at them i'm saying that because
that looks to me like it might be the
case
so that seems to work i mean
again it seems to work yeah so jordan in
one second i want to ask you a little
bit
about the something that you're saying
here uh you know mentoring
and and teaching uh and the role of that
in a society that really has decided
that those who attempt to mentor those
who attempt to teach are violating a
personal sense of authenticity i want to
ask you about that in just one second
first let's talk about how you can save
on your business by using stamps.com so
going to the post office why would you
do that you know the post office is
great
have a lot of great services but thanks
to stamps.com you don't have to go to
the post office at all or wait in line
do any of that stuff instead you can
mail and ship anytime anywhere right
from your computer you can send letters
ship packages and pay less a lot less
with discounted rates from usps ups
and more here at daily wire we've been
using stamps.com since 2017.
you know waste our time and we don't
waste our money stamps.com brings the
services of the us postal service and
ups directly to your computer
whether you're a small office sending
invoices a side hustle etsy shop
shipping out orders
or you're just navigating the hybrid
work life stamps.com can handle it all
with ease simply
use that computer prints official us
postage 247 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just schedule a pickup or drop it
off
with stamps.com you get discounts up to
40 off post office rates you're saving a
lot of money
up to 66 off ups shipping rates
stamps.com is a no-brainer it takes you
time
it saves you money i always want to save
time and money and i do pretty much
everything online
why wouldn't you do the same thing stop
wasting your time going to the post
office instead
go to stamps.com there's no risk with my
promo code shapiro
you get a special offer it includes a
four week trial plus free postage and
digital skill
no long-term commitments for contracts
just head on over to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that's
stamps.com
promo code shapirostamps.com never go to
the post office again
so jordan you were talking about that
the power of mentoring the powering uh
the power of uh and and fulfillment more
than power
of of helping people achieve the best in
themselves
and this brings me to a i think a deeper
question about the nature of identity in
the modern world there's a book i found
myself citing frequently these days by
carl truman
called the ryzen triumph of the modern
self and his basic proposition is that
the failure of western civilization over
the course of the last several decades
is largely attributable to a false
version of what constitutes the self
his basic case is that most people
understand this
innately with regard to their own
children their children are innocent and
children are cute and children are
barbarians and it is your job as a
parent to civilize children
and to civilize children means exactly
what it sounds like it is to take
children
and then to enmesh them in a framework
of rules and values that make them
better people and so identity is what
grows
out of the interaction between yourself
and a society that surrounds you and a
set of rules that are meant to make you
better
and allow you to practice to get better
at being you and helping others and
is acting as a citizen within a
functional society
the the modern version of self is almost
precisely the opposite and that is
that true meaning is not to be found in
the interaction between you and society
true meaning is to be found in your
authentic self free of society's
constraints so every sort of constraint
that could be placed on your notion
of authentic self-identification is a
barrier to happiness
and so biology can be a barrier to
happiness if you're a man you believe
you're a woman this means that you're a
woman and anybody who says differently
even using objective measures like
biology this person is actually a threat
to you
if you are a believer that children
ought to be
enmeshed in a system of religious values
that propagates
and has been propagating uh the notion
of basic morality for several thousand
years
that is an imposition on you as an
authentic human being that the authentic
person is the person who is free
of society who's free of civilization
sort of rusolian
natural savage living completely absent
all of the restrictions of the
surrounding society and when you talk
about you know the power of mentorship
and the power of teaching
you're assuming that that identity is
really more formed or more properly
formed
in that connection between the human
being and the society surrounding them
uh than it is by simply looking within
and finding the fulfillment you seek
only within
yes that's very complicated question and
so i'll take it apart a couple of ways i
just had a
outstanding scientist on my podcast and
he's the world's foremost authority on
the development of aggression
male and female and there are different
patterns and so
he was a russoian to begin with he
believed that
we're born good essentially in that we
learn aggression
through modeling through all sorts of
pathways but fundamentally that it's
learned but he's
conducted studies for four decades
longitudinal studies with thousands and
thousands of children
he like ate up 30 of the social science
research budget in quebec at one point
huge studies top rate he won the
equivalent of the nobel prize for
criminology in 2017
and he had his view completely turned
around and so here's the facts
so aggression is there right from the
beginning so let's say that drive to
power
and he defined aggression very
specifically
measurably kicking hitting biting and
stealing
which you can observe in children as
young as two
the motivation for such things is there
earlier than two but
children aren't very mobile before that
so they can't really manifest them
if you group children together in
groups of the same age the most violent
people are two-year-olds
by a lot okay but having said that
30 of 2 year olds virtually are never
aggressive
50 use aggression some of the time
and 17 percent use it chronically
and their disproportionately male
and disproportionately from families
that are headed by very young disturbed
single mothers
and some of that's poor prenatal care in
pregnancy
and some of its postnatal lack of
socialization that that's how it appears
and he's done intervention studies
showing that if you support these women
that you can moderate that the outcome
but we won't talk about that
here's the crucial thing across the
board
those three categories of children
non-violent sometimes violent and
chronically violent
across the board except for the
non-violent ones of course because
they're not violent
the level of aggression decreases with
age
dramatically even among the most violent
children
so the fundamental consequence of
socialization is
peace not aggression
okay the there's a subset of the violet
kids who don't get socialized by the age
of four
they're much more likely to be
anti-social
criminal delinquents and long-term
violent criminals
and partly that's because if they're not
socialized by the age of four
they can't make friends and friends are
the fundamental
el fundamental
agents of socialization from four
onwards increasingly and so if you get
knocked out of the peer group because
you can't
reciprocate and use violence as a
strategy
then you fall further and further behind
and become more and more alienated
and so the russoian view has its pluses
because 30 percent of kids
aren't violent at all but the hobbesian
view which is that we're born in
a chaotic and aggressive state of nature
every dog for himself let's say
also has its truth but
but what's so interesting is that social
as children are socialized the level of
aggression goes down now you see if
power
was an effective strategy what would
happen is that the most successful kids
would become more
aggressive with time and that isn't what
happens at all
so we're way too complicated to
only rely on ourselves we're social to
the core
i mean and it's a tenet it's so
interesting because it's a tenet
particularly of philosophy on the left
that human beings are almost infinitely
malleable socially
so how can you believe that and also not
believe that socialization is a main
pathway to
to genuine authenticity you can't
believe why you can because you can
believe both of those things at the same
time and nothing horrible will happen to
you but they're still logically
contradictory
so no we flower inside institutions
we're
they're not our enemy it's a myth ben
it's a myth it's the same thing it's the
tyrannical patriarchy killing the
natural soul it's like yes
because every society demands its pound
of flesh
and we're all crushed and bent and
warped by
our socialization insofar as it was
based on deceit and power and
and in so far as our institutions were
inadequate
that's true but it's not it's not enough
of the truth
it's not enough look at our very
language every word we speak was
invented by other people every word we
speak we've agreed on the meaning
everything we do is social to the core
that's not all our enemy that's
that's a myth it's peter pan versus
captain hook
and peter pan never grows up and the
patriarchy isn't captain hook
crooks are captain hook jordan in just a
second i want to ask about
uh your definition of ideology because
one of the
the slurs that has been thrown at you is
that you are some sort of ideologue
um but you say in your book that it's
important to abandon ideology so i want
to get your
definition of ideology in just one
second first let's talk for a second
about the importance if you're a
responsible human being actually
of getting life insurance you know if
you're a responsible person you want to
make sure that your
family is taken care of if god forbid
something happens to you you want life
insurance but
here's the thing it can be hard to find
a great life insurance program a lot of
people tend to do it by word of mouth
that's not the best way to do it you
should be doing it online
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place and save 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
you can feel great knowing your family
has financial protection first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
you can compare quotes and find your
best price since their licensed agents
actually work for you not the insurance
companies there's no hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of it for you
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased advice they're
totally
free to use policy genius can promise
you won't leave their website feeling
foolish you could save 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes feel great knowing if something
happens your loved ones
will be taken care of go to
policygenius.com to get started today
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and super important to get it
right
all righty jordan so in your book you
talk about abandoning ideology and the
importance of being able to
be i think almost playful with ideology
a little bit and i think
this is something with which i i deeply
agree you know listen i'm a committed
conservative in terms of my social
values i'm very committed
uh to my values as far as where i think
the role of government lies and doesn't
lie
but one of the points that you make is
that it's very important
to avoid being a rigid ideologue to the
point where you're completely
inflexible to the point where your
ideology completely throws out
all the evidence on any proposition and
prevents you from being able to see
truth
well it depends on whether you want to
solve problems or be right
you can't be both of those and and
that's one of the tremendous advantages
of science is if you want to be a
scientist you have to abandon being
right
you have to be wrong all the time and
learn
and often learn that the opposite of
what you presumed was true
but and the same is true if you're a
real engineer
in my first book maps of meaning i tried
to provide a technical definition of
ideology
and so i developed what i thought was a
map of meaning hence the name of the
book which is that
a full it's predicated on the idea that
we inhabit stories that we look at the
world through a story which is why
stories are so attractive to us and
a story is about people in action going
from one place to a more desirable place
that's our life we're going from one
place to a more desirable place and
that's punctuated by
catastrophes of various magnitude
and we have to cope with those
catastrophes and um
that's like the rise and fall of israel
in the old testament so
it's got that structure and it's the
story of
of in the individual end of society well
there are characters you meet along the
way and you need to know about all the
characters you need to know about
the positive element of nature that's
what the environmentalists worship
gaia in her beauty and benevolence and
plenitude
and that echoes through representations
of mary for example in christianity
i'm not reducing one to the other i'm
just pointing out how these things
interplay there's the negative element
of nature that's
the witch that's the swamp that's
death and disease and mortality and the
forces that are conspiring in the
natural world to destroy us and
the social world is the same there's a
benevolent element the wise king and a
tyrannical element the tyrant and
in the individual there's the heroic
and the adversary the hero and the
adversary that's christ and satan that's
played out all the time especially in
pop culture the the hostile brother
motif is unbelievably common thor and
loki is
an example batman and joker superman and
lex luthor it's it's there everywhere
it's there because we all contend with
the malevolence in our own soul
that's part of why it's there so
a religious structure represents all of
that
and a comprehensive philosophy
represents all of that you see that in
freud freud had a representation in his
thought system of every single one of
those categories so
the ego was bipolar the super egos the
social world was bipolar
the id the natural world was bipolar
freud covered the
territory and so he could sneak
mythology back into science because he
got his
story right an ideology just takes
fragments of that
and it derives its power from the
underlying religious truth
so you're a rebellious hero
rejecting the demands that society makes
on you because of its corrupt and
deceitful and tyrannical nature
it's like yes true
but it's an ideology because it's not
true enough it's missing the rest of the
story
and so you need the rest of the story
it's not optional
to know this you don't know it and
you're in big trouble
so for example if you don't understand
that there's malevolence in your own
soul and you only see it in the external
world
you're not going to be able to adapt to
the external world it's going to turn
itself
into your enemy you're going to never
grow up because you won't
adopt any responsibility because you
can't distinguish it from tyranny
these things have real consequences you
know and if you only see
nature as benevolent then you have no
appreciation for what society is
protecting you from and
you have no sense of the fundamental
fragility of human beings
so an ideology parasitizes
a religious trope that's what it does
that's why it has power
and so it appeals to us instinctively
and
because it's a half truth or a quarter
truth but but it's a quarter true so i
tried in maps of meaning to say look
here's the
here's the entire symbolic world
and you need to understand it so you
don't fall prey to
partial misrepresentations so that's
part of it the other part is
the problem with an ideology is it
doesn't actually tell you what to do
no not if you actually want to solve a
problem so with tremblay for example
when he was studying aggression
he had to decompose his original a prior
assumptions which were basically russoia
people are good and they learn to be
aggressive
he had to learn in high resolution
and then he realized that well one thing
you could do to decrease
some manifestations of aggression among
some children
some of the time was to provide
single mothers who were young and poorly
educated and who
manifested signs of psychopathology
which doctors can pick up very very
easily
provide them with support during
pregnancy in the first year or two of
their life and their children are much
more likely to
fall out of the violent category and the
long-term return on investment is
extremely positive
now that's high resolution thinking he
actually wanted to solve the problem
the ideology just tells you what to
think about everything so you're always
right
and someone else is always wrong and
even worse they're evil
and that's where things go out of
control as soon as the evil person isn't
you
you're on shaky ground
now you know i've been criticized too
because i stress personal responsibility
it's like
it's not like i don't stress social
responsibility it's like but you're
loose cannon man get yourself tied down
straighten yourself the hell up see if
you can say what you believe to be true
and open your eyes and
and then and take on some responsibility
in a manner that will make you
suffer if you're wrong and then
if you can survive that trial by fire
which you can define then maybe you
can dare to start moving the dials and
levers of the broader world
it's more a call to humility than
than a denial of social responsibility
of course you're
unbelievably responsible for your
society and should do what you can to
improve it but you bloody well better
make sure that you've got yourself
together
if you're gonna go and do that because
other people will suffer for your
mistakes so jordan one of the things
that you talk about in the book which is
i think really wonderful and i hadn't
heard you talk about it a lot before
you've done in some of your lectures but
it hasn't been the main theme it's sort
of the relationship
question you know how do you maintain
romance in your relationship and as a
dude who's been married for almost 13
years
at this point i can say that you know it
it is very very good advice i mean the
amount of work that has to go into a
relationship to keep a relationship
functioning at a high level
is tremendous and that's not what you
are sold in the media what you're sold
in the media
is number one the happily ever after
wedding ending but
even that is now hacked now the idea is
that there is no happily ever after that
basically you're a fool if you get
married and that true happiness lies
in changing partners on a fairly routine
basis but that's not the case that you
make at all you make the case that
happiness is going to lie and
fulfillment more importantly is going to
lie
in the hard work of of putting romance
into your relationship and and people i
think
when they get into this thing they don't
know how much work it is
to even do the sort of thing where you
plan you have to plan romance into your
life particularly after you have kids
it's a reality
i had a lot of clinical experience you
know and i had
men in my practice who were very
successful
serial
serially sexually active and
it didn't work for them very well now i
would say
very forthrightly if i had
two men and all other things being equal
one was capable of serial sexual
relationships and was attractive enough
to manage that and the other wasn't that
the person who
managed to do that is more successful i
believe that
so if you're abstinent because you're
incapable that is not a virtue
but you can't divorce something
as miraculous
as sexuality from your life how are you
gonna do that
well you can trivialize it it's nothing
well okay well then then
then you have nothing so good luck with
that
you're gonna take one of the deepest
sources of meaning that's available to
you
and turn it into nothing well
that's its own punishment well
so then you integrate it into your life
well what do you want for your life do
you
i mean do you want to be
what what is what is it that you want
from sex do you want intimacy do you
want closeness
do you even want the experience to be of
high quality do you want the person to
pay
attention to you well they're going to
have to care for
you i mean lust will get you somewhere
and it's not nothing but but it's by no
means everything
and and everyone knows this
people are lonely they they need and
they need someone to communicate with
and they need someone to
tie themselves together with so their
lives make a rope they need someone to
communicate
with when times are good and to share
their triumphs and they need
someone to share their catastrophes and
they need a framework that's stable so
that they can have children
and well why would you have children
it's like that's a stupid question
it's like well what else are you gonna
do
you know i mean there aren't that many
things that make up your life
and intimate relationships that's 20 of
your life or 30
of your life children that's 20 of your
life now you can get away with neither
of those but
you better have a walloping career or a
tremendous
aptitude at something creative and
remarkable
and maybe you can do that maybe that'll
be enough for you but
i've seen that uni-dimensionality work
out well
very very very very very rarely
so and you have children because you
won't have
you'll never have the opportunity in
your life to have as high quality
relationship with anyone as you could
potentially have with your child
so you're going to forego that well you
can but
what's left for you then all this
cynicism
it you know what it's aimed against
blind obedience it's like fair enough
okay so i would
take a cynic over someone who's blindly
obedient any day
especially a cynic who was once blindly
obedient
because at least then they had managed
that but
if you're really cynical you move past
cynicism
you doubt your doubt and you start to
notice
and then you engage in your life and so
young people are being sold a shoddy
bill of goods
even if you're successful at what you
pursue say serial sexual satisfaction
tinder you're a hot tinder item it's
like
well if you're a male and you're
attractive and you have an endless array
of willing females
it's a gateway to psychopathy as far as
i'm concerned
because you have to divorce your
sexuality
from the humanity of the people that
you're
engaged with sexually well all that's
gonna do is make you hard and bitter
and i wouldn't recommend it so
and it's not casual moralizing
you know i'm not suggesting that
naive abstinence is the right
solution
we're not doing a good job ben of of
communicating
the fundamental values of life to you
our young people i've got a story to
tell you man
i i talked to this woman this week you
and me park and
she wrote a book called in order to live
she's an escapee from
north korea and like she had quite the
life man like
starvation then slavery was that kind of
sums up her life
she had to sell her own mother whom she
loved
i mean just think about that for like 15
minutes to see where it gets you
and and she was literally a slave in
china
and she struggled through all that ended
up in south korea and went to a south
korean
university she did all her education in
one year
elementary junior high and high school
in one year passed the ged and got into
a competitive south korean university
it's like this is quite the girl
and she her book it wraps up in 2015
so i asked her about what's happened in
recent years she went to columbia
university
so imagine this girl struggles out of
north korea
and slavery and pursues her education
and gets to go to an ivy league school
in new york it's like the pinnacle of
her ambition she was
drastically affected by george orwell's
night uh
animal farm when she was in south korea
it's one of the first
classic books she read and that's what
made her decide to write and to speak
so she can understand the value of the
humanities like
virtually no one else can she went to
columbia
i said well how was that she said
it was a complete waste of time and
money and i said well wait a second
you can't you can't really mean that
surely
in your four years studying humanities
at columbia
you must have had one professor or one
course
that spoke to you you know the way that
the books that you were reading spoke to
you that
that the person made the attempt to push
past
the limitations of the institution and
and mentored you she mentioned one
human biology class where she learned
about evolution
but said that that was all twisted by
political correctness near the end
and that was all she could muster up for
four years of
of she said that she felt just about as
stymied in her freedom of speech
at columbia university studying
humanities as she did in bloody north
korea
that's what we're doing to our young
people it's so
appalling so appalling
there's so much that people can be
offered
this richness of the past so much that's
desperately necessary this isn't
optional
the idea that man does not live by bread
alone
that's not religious claptrap
that's she said she was in this room in
south korea a little room
full of books she studied so hard she
had to go to the hospital because she
forgot to eat
i said a little room isn't little if
it's full of books
so jordan in a second i want to ask you
a few final questions
starting with the the theme that you
talk about very often
of gratitude in spite of suffering and
also i want to ask you about
the changing cultural standards and more
as you mentioned that we were abandoning
so much in the past is there a natural
limit to that
or is that something that's going to
have to be actively fought back against
but if you'd like to hear jordan's
answers you have to be a daily wire
member head on over to dailywire.com
click subscribe you can hear the rest
of our conversation over there well
jordan it's always an honor and a
pleasure to have you on the program
again folks
you need to go out and buy jordan's
brand new book beyond order 12 more
rules
for life it is a fantastic sequel to a
fantastic book jordan thanks so much for
joining the show and it's great to see
you
thanks ben it was really good to see you
and thanks for everything
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pava wiedowsky
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
title graphics are by cynthia angulo the
ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021